this is a production of cornell
university
the first is
one of my graduate students phd student
in plant breeding maylynn murdoch
and the focus of her research
remote sensing
uh
mainly for phenotyping in our breeding
program but also eventually perhaps for
crop management
but what we have done here at this stop
is built in a lot of free time
because uh in this trial here there is
quite a bit of genetic variability
and
we want it to give you the opportunity
to walk through the field and see the
phenotypic differences and ask us
questions
so with no further ado i will pass the
mike to may
thank you larry
as larry said my name is maelyn murdock
i'm a first year going into my second
year phd student um the interest in
digital agriculture specifically remote
sensing
as it applies to hemp breeding and
production systems and there is an
additional speaker today
kathleen i'll let her introduce herself
hi i am not working in half my name is
kathleen and i work with grapes but may
and i are doing very related sort of
investigations and using similar tools
um so how we'd like to kind of organize
this we're going to do a brief
introduction and then we're going to
split into two groups um one group will
be in the field with me and another
group would be here with kathleen um
kind of talking about sensors and
applications and more you know give you
guys more chances to really ask your
questions about remote sensing
applications um so just a quick show of
hands how many are familiar with the
term remote sensing
we love this how many are familiar with
the
you know drones and use of drones for
agriculture
okay nice well then i'll give a brief
kind of overview what it means to remote
sense and
our aims and goals here so
essentially remote sensing is learning
collecting information
about the earth's surface without being
in contact to it specifically i'm
interested in him
kathleen rapes
and we utilize drones on a week to week
honestly daily basis besides the
weekends uh
and you know we've been doing this the
entire summer almost i think trying to
figure out how to best acquire
digital traits and correlate them with
you know what we see in the field with
our eyes on a day-to-day basis
so our aim
with remote sensing is essentially to
kind of bridge the gaps uh with you know
genetic improvements you know we can do
a lot genetically now but there's not a
lot we can do phenotypically
unless you have a large or big team with
you right um and i know many growers and
farmers you know have large larger
acreages of this than we have so really
we hope to
improve the status of how can you
collect being a typical data and like
how can you do that at a high throughput
um
so so we're going to split into two
groups
the group that will be me will go and
talk about this field trial
and then the group that will be here
we'll talk about sensors and
applications two different drones that
do two different things so right over
here this is called the m100
and this guy has two cameras on it so
there's the white one over here that's a
near infrared camera and those are
wavelengths that we as humans don't pick
up but they're just outside the visible
range and they're
great for monitoring things like plant
health because they give you a lot of
information about the structure of
different leaves so
when really any type of stress is
affecting a plant and the leaves either
start to wilt or maybe looking a little
bit yellower then your infrared is
really sensitive to that so that's the
reason why that added camera is there
and then the red green blue camera is
there's a little red device under there
so that's what's on this drone and as
you can tell this is smaller right so
it's a lot it's a lot more lightweight
it can go a lot further and be in the
air for longer because it's not carrying
as much
this is the m600 obviously a lot bigger
um and this has two sensors on it one of
them
is this camera down here
and that actually does 10 different wave
bands so you've got red green blue but
you've also got
finer gradations within that spectrum
and that's again really helpful because
not only are we getting
things that we could pick up if we were
in the air but we also get more
information from different ranges of the
electromagnetic spectrum that we can't
see um
there's also a thermal camera on this
one and that gives obviously information
about temperature so
as many of you guys probably know
evapotranspiration and model conductance
are two metrics that can tell us a lot
about
what's happening in a particular plant
and being able to see that from up high
and see maybe areas where
your plants are looking a lot hotter
in one particular part of the field than
another could be really informative
especially when we're thinking about
things like irrigation water stress and
also for some diseases
so these are the two tools that we are
using and may and i primarily actually
have been flying them 600 this summer to
get a little bit finer detail
um
when we go out with these drones
there are a couple of steps that are
required to make a flight happen so one
of those is the flight plan
we are not because we're using this for
data collection we want things to be
pretty consistent
we have an a flight plan that's the same
every week so we're not manually flying
this over this field it's a
pre-programmed flight that we set up and
that ensures that the drone will follow
the exact same path every week so that
we have consistency over time um we can
obviously fly it manually if something
were to occur and go wrong and we needed
to switch that up
and that's what the remote control here
is for and so this little stand is where
you would put a smartphone a tablet so
you could sort of
see your path
on the phone and that's where you would
also be able to do things like land it
automatically if you wanted to and then
the joysticks are for the actual
manual flight
and as an example you can see the flight
plan that we have for this field up here
and you guys feel free to come closer if
you want
but it's a pretty standard
sort of area scan so it's a rectangular
back and forth and back and forth and
back and forth and you can switch things
right like you can make it fly lower you
can make it fly higher you can tighten
up the interval between those
consecutive paths over the field if you
want to have many many overlapping
images
any questions about any of this thus far
or not
collect data that you know you're
collecting uh digital images
and you see you suspect that there's
something that's happening there uh pest
infestation something how do you
corroborate that or validate that
on the ground that's a really good
question so may and i have a slightly
different project i'm working with
disease and so for us ground truthing
corroboration looks like weekly scouting
and for me it's a vineyard but so every
week on the same day that the drone
flies we go out and we look at every
single vine and we say okay on this vine
this is our percentage of infection and
then at the end of the season take those
digital images from that particular day
and say all right this is what we got
from the image whether that's a
vegetation index or whether that's a
specific band and see what's the
relationship between that index or
between the value of that band
and the level of disease we saw mae is
using it for something slightly
different because she's looking at sort
of different traits and differentiating
between different types of plants
so her ground truthing is actually a lot
more extensive so they're taking things
like heights like leaf diameter
they've been doing i guess we've both
been doing stomatal conductance but for
different reasons um
so
it depends what your right what you want
to use the digital energy for will
determine the measurements you take on
the ground to validate that but that is
a really critical piece of this because
at the end of the day this will give you
a picture
that picture is pretty much useless
unless you know something about
what was happening on the ground at that
particular time
so are these going to be made available
to farmers
so the idea is
at least
right now
we're interested in figuring out what
are those relationships and if a farmer
does have a drone and has images
sort of turning that image into
information and making that a very
seamless
process
um
these can
range in cost as you might imagine from
like hundreds of dollars to thousands of
dollars so the model for
application on a given farm will
probably look very different from place
to place um one of the things that i
think would be really amazing is if
there was sort of like a central service
right okay there's the drone team
i want my field scanned i called this
person the field the scan happens and
then i get basically a map of either
crop health or maybe heights or biomass
or whatever it is that i'm interested in
you've just become the entrepreneur
there you go there you go you need to do
that that's yeah
that's not obviously i'm a phd student
that's not what i'm here for but that's
like something that you know is
interesting to think about right is okay
what is and i that's kind of why i got
into this in the first place with yeah
how do we bring this to an actual farm
and what would that look like so
eventually the user would not actually
have to do his or her own ground
trooping yep exactly and i think they're
i mean
yes and no right this will never replace
a person this is never going to be
smarter than a human
um but the idea would be that
for example if you have hundreds of
acres to manage and you're concerned
about a particular
pastor particular
um disease
having an idea of this is where i want
to look first because i know based on my
images that this particular quadrant of
the field is looking a lot more stressed
out than everywhere else and maybe
that's where to
sort of begin that process of okay i
want to focus here see what's going on
um and manage accordingly
so not as a replacement i would say but
more so as a as a compliment as a tool
um to make this a little bit easier
you mentioned a flight plan so you have
to have a pilot's license and you do
have a pilot's license um
and it's
relatively almost scarily easy to obtain
one um
you don't have to prove that you can fly
it you just have to know the rules about
okay where are you allowed to fly a
drone and where are you not allowed to
fly a drone and sort of things take into
account as far as like air conditions
and
um
and most of it is safety it's a bit like
getting a permit before you get your
driver's license
but it's administered through the faa
you can
prepare for the exam online take it
they're testing centers all over the
country so
it's yeah the actually the licensing
process is
quite straightforward
a large grape producer large fruit
producer could certainly be able to
afford their own drone and market yeah
absolutely
yep and the software to make these
flight plans is also
very easy to obtain
um i think the biggest i don't know the
biggest sort of
missing piece would be that turning the
images right into information that i
think is the part that we're we're
trying to make simpler and much faster
than it is right now
so this is speculation but
yeah um they are
below certain wind speeds they're very
very stable so we cannot fly this
with wind speeds above 12 miles an hour
it would not um be advisable
but that being said i mean when wind
speeds are under 12 miles an hour it's
really really stable so you don't you
don't see it up there
shaking around
so what is this
this we're looking at we're right about
there actually right now um
yeah i do check this every morning but
we are at
15 or so yeah
yeah let's see what we got
yeah we've got average eight gusts of
18.
what's your battery life
yeah good question so um this one takes
six batteries and these are the little
slots where they go in
that will get us
about 23 total minutes of flight time
so it takes when we scan this field
that's about a seven minute scan
so we could do that three times would be
pushing it but we could do that three
times and again like the length of your
skin depends on how high you're flying
how many times you want to
pass over
um but yeah but also wind speed so wind
speed does it does impact that yeah how
fast is it
you can set that we for scans like this
we set it at two meters per second or
three meters per second um but you could
fly it i mean
you probably wouldn't i wouldn't want to
fly it over five meters per second but
you could you definitely could still get
the same information you get the same
well you get the same information but
you might not get the best quality of
images because you would get sort of
imagine it's flying
quicker so the captures even if you're
capturing at the same rate you might not
get as much overlap between your images
so you could have
perhaps one image of the same sort of
footprint on the ground
whereas when we fly at a lower speed you
would get maybe three emmit three
overlapping images of that same area so
if one image is a little bit off you
would have sort of a backup
how long is that one gonna last
this guy
i think you would we could probably get
35 on a set of batteries
um
yeah
yeah
so
what's the cost of that bigger one there
this with no
cameras and actually it's funny the
cameras are usually the more expensive
piece with no cameras
i want to say that one comes in around
10
grand yeah you'll see those in the
with the cameras
i i'm going to be honest i don't know
how much these cameras cost
um i didn't want to ask
this one much
much less so we're i think probably
about half as much
for that one if that yeah without the
camera without the camera
so how is the how do you identify the
individual plants
are they are you
you have steak
tags out there or
it depends yeah it depends on the field
what we do for
grapes is we have we basically went out
and we took the location of each post
that's in the vineyard and so we know
okay we have those those points right in
the image where we know the posts are so
in between those points
within a certain width that's our our
vine
for for things like hemp like for this
field
from the picture you see very clearly
where the individual plants are but
there is a bit of manual work that goes
into sort of segmenting out this is kind
of small
and that well yeah and that's a huge
challenge to image processing is
quickly obtaining only the areas that
you want right if you don't care about
the tarp you don't want to be analyzing
the tarp but segmenting out the parts
that you you care about
that's a challenge for sure yeah
now you have a program that processes
the images to kind of give you like
to a certain extent yes um but the
segmentation piece that's something that
we're working on to automate that that
does not exist yet
and we're hoping to build that so that
you could write feasibly scan
100 acres and then
say okay of that 100 acres i want to
look at only the pixels that correspond
to my crop and not the not the weeds not
the dirt nothing else
you mentioned that your your area is
diseased
and you can also tell from the imagery
if the vines are being drought stressed
or stressed for other reasons
could also be used in the spring to see
if there is freeze death so if you wait
when the vines are coming out of
dormancy and fly it then you can see how
many vines are
not
producing any yeah yeah that's a really
good question and we're we're working on
that right now not with um drones but
with
proximal sensors you actually mount on a
tractor and so there are cameras you
would not on the tractor and you go
through the vineyard and they take yeah
they take images of each side of the
tractor so each row and with that you
get readings from the canopy so you can
tell exactly when
everything is starting
to push out shoots okay if there was a
lot of winter kill there are some plants
that you're not going to see any green
whatsoever and that will come out um so
that's one of the applications that
we're looking at to kind of get a better
sense at the very beginning of the
season okay how much
right how much winter damage is there
and is there anything that we can do
with pruning to
make sure that
there's a decent crop load
and where could i look up information on
those sensors to mount on a four wheeler
or side by side
where could i look for that yeah there
is if you look so there's a company
called cropscape that has the sensors
that we've been using um for grapes
and
for i mean for the drones the i would
say dji so the letters dji that's the
company that manufactures these two and
is probably at this point
one of the better i guess better known
but also higher quality for research
purposes manufacturers of drones um
and they have a lot of
sort of
options as far as pieces of equipment
and sensors
so you could get a used drone probably
much cheaper i i bet you could yeah 100
and you know that's not by any means the
only company like there there are many
that are
equally good as far as quality goes um
i think it's more about right
learning the on the user side making
sure that
the person is comfortable with flying it
uh so
i'm sure you guys had a lot of great
conversations with kathleen over there
learning about sensors and applications
and you're definitely more than welcome
to ask me a bit about it last session we
kind of got drifted away and talking
about
seats and seats company so we'll try to
keep this one more specific to to remote
sensing
so like i said our aim cornell hemp's
aim with remote sensing it's really you
know this is kind of a foundational
trial
for the remote sensing efforts with
cornell hemp and i
only in my second year now so i'm really
hoping to kind of
refined this in my later years
but this is our you're sitting you're
standing really in our white space trial
and this white space trial has four
different populations
um
two are quote quote cultivars um you can
see very quickly that this is not
uniform and to be a cultivar you need to
be uniform um and then the last two down
there which we'll go over in the next
session with jacob are some of our own
cornell hemp produced uh populations so
yeah
what i mean by white space is seven and
a half feet by seven and a half feet
you'll notice that we have black uh weed
fabric here and we have beds with black
tarp this really helps me in my remote
sensing efforts like i said we do
weekly
daily flights really
and a lot of ground truthing
measurements so this kind of helps
keep the weeds away and really pinpoint
the plant of interest that we need
so our goal with this trial specifically
is plant architecture growth stages and
yield estimation it's been done in a lot
of crops and this one has had a lot of
literature supporting so now we just
need to
all we need to do right is kind of make
those studies happen
then have a good model for prediction
for farmers and growers to use
so in that our specific goals here are
extensive phenotyping like i said
me and the rest of the cornell ha
research team a good amount of us are
here on a weekly basis measuring height
diameter
getting leaf area
sampling you know getting a lot of these
measurements to really correlate and
truth rate our
drone flight in our imagery that we get
we also aim to reconstruct individual
plants so creating individual plant
models and that would be with lidar
sensors
i'm sure kathleen went over what lidar
sensors are so
yeah
do
definitely reconstruct what sorry
flipping here um
reconstruct individual plant models and
then with like multi-spectral sensors
like as i'm sure she mentioned
to really evaluate vegetation indices
and i'm sure she went over a couple of
them already so this makes it a great
group to talk to um but essentially
knowing those for you know
plant health knowing those for disease
knowing those for
what my bio mass might be at the end of
the season
really just
having a lot so the goal is yeah
reconstruct the models evaluate the
indices those taken together essentially
would allow us to identify the optimal
digital traits
needed to
gather that information in terms of
yield estimation right so then we no
longer have a cornell hemp research team
crew coming out here on a week-to-week
basis we have a flight team maybe of two
to five not not a lot doing this on a
weekly week basis and
sitting at the computer in
nice cool air instead of being out here
on a hot day
with that like i said this is a very
foundational trial for me and so i'm
through this i'm also exploring things
like color
impacts of color
things like sex determination uh
chemotyping right do i have a high thc
plant do i have a high cbd plant
and flowering time so these first two
populations we have out here that i
mentioned
you could see the variability in
flowering time we've had stuff starting
in early july and i'm sure we're still
going to get
flowering starting like in october
so really doing that on a weekly basis
would allow us to see you know what
is you know what's going on with this
population also too we're getting
genetic data so that already like
confounds it a lot more and gives us
more information that we need
and those last two populations down
there
are
a basis for color exploration and kind
of
you know plant yield um
but
yeah do we have any questions
are you like when you fly over are you
determining heights of the plants as
well yes so on a bi-weekly or
week-to-week basis we are collecting
height data with a team of four to five
people out here and then with the drones
we're going to be able to see and kind
of correlate those height measurements
with the drone measurements and you can
do that essentially with like a digital
elevation model
a digital surface model
of your field and if you know your plant
layout and have some kind of marker so
you'll see throughout the field we have
like these things called gcps they're
like white tiles and what that stands
for is ground control points and that
allows us to not only overlay week by
week for the same points but if say if
we had those gcps raised it would allow
us to benchmark that we know that this
gcp is always at this height and if a
plant is at this height so another
method to kind of
really
support what we're seeing in terms of
height
you've got a plant a week ago that was
standing straight up you've got a lot of
wind from the west which i see yeah the
plants sitting at a 25 degree angle so
the height is actually less than it was
correct so the height actually is the
actual the height that we get on the
weak tweet bases is the above ground
level height not the stem length or what
the actual height of the plant would be
this is that measuring from the ground
to the aperture
yeah so for instance if we come over
here a bit you can kind of see this one
is a bit large if i stood it up properly
that would be the height but our height
measurements on the week to week basis
only goes from
the above ground level because that's
exactly
yep that's exactly what the drone is
going to see and then the nice thing
about having it on a week to week you
can also the nice thing with drones is
you can also get percent lodging
they do that and a lot of other crops so
then we'll be able to know but yeah that
is the one thing you can't get what the
actual potential height of the plant
might be but you can guesstimate it from
accounting for lodging and
the height that you're getting
the leaf area yeah so with leaf area
there's leaf area index and that's
really done
yeah they do it less with multi-spectral
sensors and more with lidar sensors and
lidar sensors are the ones that is an
active sensor that shoots lasers
essentially or just shoots a laser
really and scans and so with that data
you can calculate leaf area index but
then there's also nice handheld tools
that allow us to
measure out in the field right we can go
below canopy there's a wand also called
an lai for the same purpose and it will
give us a measurement of the leaf area
index
and then we can also do leaf samples
on a weekly basis or at certain time
points to get leaf area
yeah just pick a leaf right and then try
to keep it consistent throughout the
field
you can scan it so there's also tools to
have like a flatbed scanner um
to scan the leaf but
yeah i'm going to cut our conversation
we're going to go
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu